j'ai commencé le rugby parce que mon
père a joué jusqu'à 42 ans
donc quand j'étais bébé j'étais déjà sur
sur les terrains meilleur souvenir c'est
compliqué dans une longue carrière mais
je vais parler de la demi finale de la
coupe du monde de 87
tout ce qui s'est passé avant pendant et
après pourquoi parce que c'est une
demi-finale la première coupe du monde
allait gagner contre l'australie ce
match je pense qu'elle est
extraordinaire
il ya eu une préparation qui a été très
très dur parce qu'on avait joué un match
contre les fidji juste auparavant qui
avait pas été formidable et donc jacques
fouroux nous avait mis pas mal de points
sur les i pour se remettre en question
et puis après on a on a fêté la
demi-finale entre nous d'une manière
sage mais voilà le limage s'étaient tous
les joueurs au milieu du terrain après
le match en train de chanter quelques
chansons basques avec les amis basques
qui était dans l'équipe de france
les objectifs je suis engagé d'année
avec le club de rugby d'agen cessé de
pouvoir rester en top 14
évidemment c'est d'avoir une bonne santé
de rencontrer du monde et que le coc
vide
on peut soit plus fort que lui pourquoi
me fais et puisse y avoir toujours
beaucoup de mouvement et de belles
rencontres